hello everyone 20 years ago Latin
American Cinema exploded around the
world from Mexico the names of Alejandro
Gonzalez inaru guo Del Toro Alonso Quon
rapidly became a referent for everyone
around the world and not just from
Mexico from Brazil there was Walter
sales Fernando meles Padilla from
Argentina trapero lucrecia Martel Latin
American films have been celebrated
around the globe and especially at the
Academy Awards but we're not stopping
there many filmmakers are crossing over
and expanding their careers into the
English language industry and those
stories need to be heard in the
following panel the amazing producer
Rosa Bosch will have a passionate debate
with four filmmakers that are already
shooting in English that have so much to
say and experiences to
share